it's been nearly a full year since
hogwarts legacy was unveiled back at the
ps5 showcase event in september of 2020
and there are still
some big questions fans are dying to
have answered
in today's video we're gonna go over
some of those big questions and i'm
joined today
by a very special guest to help me do
that that's right
you guys already know if you read the
title that is alex from podcast now
joins me for today's video and we're
going to give you the seven
biggest questions we still have for
hogwarts legacy
if you follow hogwarts legacy news on
youtube then you're probably already
familiar with alex but if not definitely
check out his channel where he has
a ton of content covering so many
different games in addition to hogwarts
legacy seriously the man pumps out a
ridiculous amount of
content for his audience go show him
some love guys
alex man thank you so much for joining
me on this video and i'm gonna turn it
over to you for question number one
so my first question is one that's been
asked a lot i think on youtube i know
i've specifically made videos for it
i've seen a lot of people make videos
for it is will dumbledore
be in this game it's a question i think
you need to ask yourself you need to
look yourself in the mirror
probably once a day and ask this
question it's one that i think has
pretty big ramifications it's definitely
one that's possible right but what would
that
mean i mean i think it means a lot i
mean that's a character that we all know
we all know who they are we all know
what they've
done when they get older but we've never
seen them
you know as a 11 year old boy as a 12
year you know however old
dumbledore may be again obviously the
years need to line up and they need to
line up
perfectly you really have a very small
percentage uh
chance that this happens i don't think
it's impossible in fact i've been
rooting
for this to happen since the beginning
but yeah there's a lot of stuff that can
come from this he could be a close
friend to you
uh you know i guess how much of a friend
could he become what are the
interactions like with him
i think it has a lot of ramifications on
the game itself
love that one alex okay here i'm gonna
go with a super obvious one but one i
absolutely think every fan wants to know
and that's
when is the release date thanks to the
2018 leaked trailer we know the game has
been in development for
quite some time we also know the
original plan was to release the game at
some point in 2021 but once
2021 actually got here avalanche let us
know pretty early on that the game was
being pushed all the way to 2022
and since then
yeah that's the last we've heard about
it the nebulous 2022. what's crazy is
now that we're more than halfway through
the year 2021 we could actually be
around six months away from the launch
of the game
of course that's if it's launching early
2022 i'm actually still expecting it to
be much
later in the year but probably around
the holidays but we still just don't
know avalanche give us that release date
soon okay my next question is how will
the sorting hat work
this one to me i feel like has always
been one of if not the
the biggest questions i've personally
had and it's honestly it's the first
thing that we're probably going to be
doing
in the game i mean a lot of us i think
can theorize you know you jump into the
game
you get to make your character right
character creation
maybe you name them although we're
actually not sure we nobody's really
ever mentioned that they've never talked
about it but maybe you name them
maybe you pick out a wand for them maybe
you know you customize their appearance
right
male or female and then you get sorted
into a house but how
does that part work right do you have to
answer questions is it connected to like
pottermore
there's been speculation there's been a
lot of actually really good ideas
into her into how you know the entire
thing could work and i like them and i
like
the idea i like the idea of it being
separated from the game
but at the same time i also don't
because i also feel like you maybe want
to keep everything
bound to the game so doing like an app
like a quiz on your phone
and then having that connect to the game
i feel like that's maybe one step too
far but i like the concept right
but i like it i mean you can go where
it's randomized but then you're not
gonna get what you want so like if you
want to be
a ravenclaw you want to be a slytherin
and then it just randomizes you it's
like oh that's not good but then it's
like well do you have to take a quiz
like a morality quiz are they going to
have like questions on the screen
and you have to answer you know a b c or
d or do you just get the pick do you
simply pick
you you know kind of scroll over which
house you choose
press x press a you know cleft click on
the mouse and all of a sudden you're
into it and they
play you know just a normal cut scene
that they'll play for everybody that
picks it right
there's a there's a couple ways that
they could go i think some are more
in-depth than others right i think doing
questions like a morality thing
makes it seem a little bit more personal
like you're actually
being judged you're actually being
placed versus you just picking one but
again then you may not get
the house that you want and then
automatically you're starting the game
out
playing something you don't really want
to play so it's definitely interesting
it's been a question i think since the
very beginning
and it's one i want an answer to okay
alex for number four i'm getting down to
the fine
details of hogwarts here and i want to
know if we can sneak
into other common rooms avalanches
already said we'll be able to choose our
house at the start of the game which
means they'll certainly have all of the
common rooms in the game right
but will we actually have to do four
playthroughs to see them all
if it's been a while since any of you
out there have read the books each
common room had some form
of protection designed to prevent
students from other houses from being
able to just
enter in whenever they want of course
most of us are familiar with the fat
lady portrait guarding gryffindor tower
and her requirement of a
password for students this password
would change throughout the school year
and slytherin much like the gryffindors
also used the password system
ravenclaw the house most known for its
intellect required students to answer a
riddle before entering
hufflepuff had a method of entry that
never changed requiring students to tap
a specific barrel two from the bottom
middle of the second row
in the rhythm of helga hufflepuff if
done
incorrectly they were sprayed with
vinegar so
on their own there's nothing that would
prevent any student from learning these
methods regardless of their respective
house
but will hogwarts legacy allow us to
enter any common room we wish using the
standard method
or will it require something more
involved such as polyjuice potion
in the original series harry visits all
of the common rooms except for
hufflepuff he uses polyjuice in book 2
to sneak into the slytherin common room
and then visits the ravenclaw
common room along with luna near the end
of deathly hallows
professor mcgonagall also enters
ravenclaw tower just before the battle
of hogwarts by answering a riddle
correctly
however amicus caro couldn't get in
despite attempts to break the door
down fans will also remember sirius
attempted to break into gryffindor tower
during book 3
but was unable to get by the fat lady
without the correct password
so at the very least it seems clear from
the series you absolutely must use the
correct method of entry
or you won't be allowed to enter no
exceptions
my final question i have a lot more but
i was i was limited uh to only three i'm
just kidding i was it's an
honor being here i'm really happy to to
be on this uh this video but my last
question
is about classes how will classes work
so and i by classes i mean
the uh like school like school lessons
not like is there different
like classes of magic wielders right um
again the possibilities i
think are endless you can do something
where you
uh set a schedule is there free time can
you go around the hall
you know around like the corridors can
you skip classes are there punishments
for that
do classes tie into like skill points or
magic or maybe you learn something in
the class that gives you an ability
that you otherwise wouldn't be able to
get or maybe you can maybe you go to the
library and you can study and you can
read books and you can learn
the same thing that way so maybe you
skip classes but you learn it
through fighting or you learn it through
the library you know i think again the
possibilities are endless can you
interact with the professors in classes
can you interact with students uh
again can you make like your own
schedule do you have like a counselor
in the beginning of the year that you
get to pick your you know your six
classes
even the number you know how how in
depth are there are there like
three of them is it like potions is it
defense against the dark arts like are
we limiting it to just
the big ones everybody kind of knows or
are we doing some
like obscure ones that very few people
maybe remember or know about
how many is there 10 is there 15 is
there four those are all things again
uh it may not sound like a big thing but
i mean you could be spending a
substantial amount of time in this game
in classes i don't know if they would go
the persona route right that would be a
very different way of doing it
and that's honestly not the way a lot of
people have speculated so i'm really
excited to see
how classes work because i think they
connect to pretty much everything in the
game
awesome alex and thanks so much again
for joining me for this video
next another question i'm so curious
about how many
spells are in the game spell casting is
obviously going to be a huge component
and will play a major role in how the
game
actually plays if i'm being honest here
this is something i never felt like the
original games were able to nail
just right they each kind of had their
own way of trying to
tackle it and we even had various
motions and wand movements with some of
the wii
versions but they never really captured
the essence of being a powerful wizard
with a number of different spells at our
disposal to use
anytime we want one thing that often
held those games back was how the spells
were contextual in nature
there was frequently just one way to
solve a problem and only one specific
spell to get past certain obstacles
i hope hogwarts legacy is able to think
outside the box and have a system that's
more open and one that encourages
experimentation
one of the greatest elements of the
legend of zelda breath of the wild is
just how
open the game is and how it lets you
solve problems and tackle challenges in
a way that seems best to you
it doesn't lock you into only one way to
solve a problem
we know the basic spells like lumos
alohomora stupa
will almost certainly be in the game but
what about the more obscure spells like
aguamenti will there be a chance to
learn the patronus charm or what about
ridiculous to take out some boggarts
and of course i know i know i can hear
you guys out there right now
shouting in the comments the
unforgivables we want the unforgivables
will they be in i don't know for
question number seven i really want to
know
how long is the game look don't get me
wrong
i love the speculating i love the
theorizing that we're doing but i also
understand where fans are coming from
when they say that we should probably
temper our expectations one of the
biggest reasons i think we're seeing
these calls to kind of reign in our
expectations is because we know so
little about the overall scope of the
game we really just don't know how
ambitious avalanche is going to be with
this project it could be a
20 hour experience or a 100 plus hour
experience
how big is the world how many story
lines and branching narrative paths will
there be will the game be truly
open like the witcher or will it follow
a mostly linear path with a few
side quests along the way the answers to
those questions is what will ultimately
determine how long the game will be
and just how much time we'll want to
spend in the world i've heard from so
many of you in the comments about how
you just want to explore hogwarts take
in every little detail
walking around the castle trust me i'm
right there with you and i hope they're
able to nail that experience and make
the game we'll want to spend
hundreds of hours exploring be sure and
let me know what questions you guys want
to have answered down in the comments
below
as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon